all right we're gonna get some more on
Barry and the rest of the nations
weather right now let's go to
meteorologist Jeff Bureau deli Jeff good
morning good morning Dana and good
morning everybody you heard Omar talking
about the rain not quite arriving yet
and that's because this is a lopsided
system it's dry on the north end wet on
the southeast end but now what's
happening is it's getting a little bit
better organized as it starts to wrap
that rain in it's good news that it's
happening late otherwise this could have
been a much stronger system but you can
see that heavy rain and those bands
beginning to rotate in to places like
New Orleans and Biloxi let's take a look
at your weather headlines and the big
story is the rain because some places
will get stuck under heavy rain bands
and because of that 15 to 20 inches of
rain is possible wind gusts will be
strong not necessarily strong for a
hurricane but still strong enough 80
miles an hour at least knocking down
trees and we already have some power
outages their maximum storm surge three
to six feet
isolated tornadoes are possible
especially on the eastern side of the
system here's the official forecast
track from the National Hurricane Center
there's this storm located about 50
miles off the coast makes landfall this
afternoon notice how slow it moves by
late tonight it's still in Central
Louisiana then it weakens to a
depression tomorrow moves up to the
north through the Mississippi Valley the
whole way it's dumping very heavy rain
and that runoff is going into the
Mississippi River so you can see the
progression of this system now wind
gusts we are gonna see wind gusts that
get past 60
at times 70 miles an hour you can see
Houma Louisiana 70 as we head through
the day we're gonna see wind gusts go up
to around 72 miles an hour in places
like Baton Rouge so bordering on
hurricane-force winds that could knock
down trees let's show you the Future
radar right now we'll take it through
the next 24 to 48 hours and notice once
the heavy rain sets up in places like
Morgan City and Baton Rouge it is there
to stay for at least 24 hours rain rates
two to three inches an hour possible
Morgan City Baton Rouge and then
everything lifts to the north and moves
up the Mississippi River Valley how much
rain are we likely to see we're gonna
see a bullseye of heavy rain that looks
to be in the white of a foot some places
probably close to 20 inches of rain
possible we see that black shading
right there so that is the big problem
rain rates two to three inches in our
flash flooding is the big concern tons
of wind but here's the interesting thing
the storm somebody said that you could
actually out walk this storm it's moving
so slowly overall for sure and backwards
by the way and the potential to dump all
that rain any chance that the levees
could be topped
you know it's let's say they have made
the system better but storms can be
tricky and if you get a lot of rain in a
short period of time over the same place
you know and all that water running into
the Mississippi River can happen so be
cautious